>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> Edward Widmer: I'm Ted Widmer.
I'm the brand new director of
the Kluge Center, and I just want
to briefly welcome you before
turning the real introduction
over to Nancy Groce.
I'm so new, in fact, that I saw
a poster announcing this talk,
and I was wondered if I could
sneak away from the Kluge Center
to attend it, because
it was so compelling;
and I didn't fully realize
it was a talk being hosted
by the Kluge Center.
[Laughter] So I'm really glad
to be here in both the capacity
of new director and a very
interested participant.
I'm also thrilled to have learned
-- I just met Sheryl yesterday,
and I'm enjoying meeting people
from all around the world
in the various divisions
of the Library,
but particularly within
the Kluge Center.
And Sheryl and I as we talked
realized that on the Earth,
this very large planet we
all inhabit, she and I lived
about four streets away from each
other in Providence Rhode Island.
Rhode Island is so small we often
don't even use street names,
and she said, "I live near the
pharmacy where you can buy wine."
[Laughter] So I'm delighted to
meet a new hometown friend hundreds
of miles away from
where we both live.
But before Sheryl begins,
I want to ask Nancy Groce
from the American Folklife Center
to do the real introduction.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Nancy Groce: Thank you and
good afternoon to everybody,
and welcome to the
Library of Congress.
Today's event is being sponsored --
sort of cosponsored
by the Kluge Center
and the American Folklife Center.
My name is Nancy Groce, and I'm
one of the staff folklorists
at the American Folklife Center.
On behalf of my center and Ted
Widmer and his colleagues here
at the Kluge Center, I'm delighted
you are able to join us here today
for a presentation
by Sheryl Kaskowitz.
Dr. Kaskowitz is a Rhode
Island based ethnomusicologist,
who was recently awarded the
prestigious John Kluge Fellowship
to pursue her research
here at the Library.
Now, one of the great things about
receiving a Kluge fellowship is
that the award allows scholars
from throughout the United States,
really, throughout the
world, to come to the Library
to pursue their research at this,
the world's largest research
facility, and to take advantage
of the strength and resources of
the Library's numerous collections.
At the American Folklife Center
where Dr. Kaskowitz has chosen
for so much of her research
during her residency,
AFC is one of 20 specialized
reading rooms here at the Library.
By itself alone, the American
Folklife Center is the world's
largest ethnographic collection.
We think we have over six million
items documenting various aspects
of traditional cultures
from more than 144 nations
and over 800 cultural groups.
Our greatest strengths
is, of course,
our holdings in American culture,
and especially American music.
We have more than 3,000
individual collections
at the American Folklife
Center, and there are many
that have never been fully explored.
Among these -- and I should add one
of the staff's favorite is a
collection of Sidney Robertson,
or she was known for her
marriage, Sidney Robertson Cowell,
which we split between our holdings
and the Music Division holding.
Robertson was a pioneering collector
whose significant contributions
to the field of folklore
and ethnomusicology have long been
overshadowed by her contemporaries,
like Alan Lomax and Charles Seeger.
Therefore, as happy as we
are to welcome Kluge fellows,
we were particularly
delighted when Sheryl arrived
to research Robertson's
rich collection.
And I should add, I just
want to give a shout-out
to AFC staff member, Kathy Kurtz
[phonetic], who is here today
who has also done significant
work on Sidney Robertson Cowell.
And but there was more than
enough material for many scholars,
and both Sheryl and
Kathy spent a lot
of time comparing notes
and working together.
So Sheryl Kaskowitz received her
PhD in music and ethnomusicology --
well actually it's in music with
a focus on ethnomusicology, right,
from Harvard University in 2011.
And she's now at Brown
University as a researcher,
as well as an independent
scholar in Rhode Island.
Her research interests
focus on popular vernacular
and participatory music making in
the US, and include both historical
and contemporary practices.
Her most recent book, "God Bless
America," which was published
by Oxford University Press in
2013, presents a social history
and an ethnography of the
iconic Irving Berlin song.
Today, she will be presenting an
overview of her current research,
and I'd like to ask you to
join me in welcoming her
for this presentation
entitled, "Delight in What it is
to be an American: Sidney Robertson
on the Road, 1935 to 1937."
[ Applause ]
>> Sheryl Kaskowitz:
Thank you so much.
I just -- thank you
to Ted and to Nancy.
It's been such a privilege
to be here as a Kluge fellow.
I'm only able to be here for four
months, which when I started felt
like a long chunk of time and
it just went really quickly.
But I especially wanted to
thank, I mean, the librarians,
the archivists who I worked with.
Everybody was so helpful and
welcoming, and especially
in the Folklife Center, Kathy Kurtz,
and Nicky Saylor, we sort of went
out on gossiping lunches
to talk about Sidney,
because they've both
done work on her.
Todd Harvey was extremely helpful
and helped me pull the audio
that I'm going to be playing
for you; and Nancy Groce
and really everybody who helped me
at the desk, really taught me how
to use the reel-to-reel machines.
So thank you.
And thank you also
to the Kluge Center.
All of the fellows, the staff,
really made it a really kind
of a once-in-a-lifetime experience.
So and also, you know, we've
had some technical difficulties,
and so whatever happens, happens
at this point is how I feel.
So just a note about
names, Sidney --
I tend to call her by her
first name because she's known
as Sidney Robertson Cowell.
She married the composer,
Henry Cowell, in 1941,
and in musicological circles,
she's known almost exclusively
with her association with him.
But because I'm dealing with
a time before she married him,
it felt strange to call her by a
name that didn't exist at the time,
so we're sort of time-traveling and
I'm calling her Sidney Robertson.
So today, I'm going to focus
my talk around three road trips
that Sidney Robertson took between
1935 and 1937, during which she came
into her own as a folk
music collector.
These trips also illuminate
some really interesting history
about the government's use of folk
music throughout the New Deal,
showing the power that these songs
of the people were seen to hold.
In one of many unpublished,
undated reminisces
that I found among her papers,
Sidney Robertson described
the pivotal moment
when she left California, quote,
"Drawn by a belated curiosity
to know more of America
than is visible
from her pleasant California
backwater,
and without any conscious intention
beyond some firsthand experience
at the current crisis
in national life,
the writer drove east
in the summer of 1935.
The logic of such a
foray by a young woman
with no resources beyond her
training in music and psychology,
some experience in progressive
education, a small car, $75,
and a driving curiosity about life
and people is not evident even now.
The reward for risk and
hardships seems ample,
for she exchanged the sentimental
tie to France and European culture
for knowledge and delight in
what it is to be an American
without at all knowing what
she was about at the time."
In 1935, Sidney Robertson was living
in Carmel and feeling restless.
In the past three years,
she had been let go
from her job directing the music
program at an alternative school,
and had amicably divorced her
husband, Kenneth Robertson,
who she'd married the year
she graduated from Stanford.
She'd just left the job as a
governess for a wealthy family
in Pebble Beach, and was living
in an artist colony in Carmel,
teaching piano and contributing
concept write-ups and book reviews
to a fledging left-leaning magazine
called "The Pacific Weekly."
As she complained in a letter
to her mother that year, quote,
"I get bored talking of
Communism and sex down here
where only a few people ever talk
about anything else," unquote.
[Laughter] Her younger
sister, Jean, had plans to go
to the Henry Street Settlement
in New York, and in April 1935,
Sidney wrote to the settlement
house's director, Helen Hall,
to offer her services
in their music programs.
She concluded the letter by writing,
quote, "You're doing the sort
of work I care most about doing,
and I hope very much eventually
to be able to contribute
to it some way."
What might have moved Sidney to
make such a drastic life change?
She may have been influenced by
her work at the Pacific Weekly,
a left-of-center paper started
by two Veteran journalists
who had settled on the coast.
The paper featured articles
and editorials sympathetic
to left-of-center causes, and
to the plight of working people.
Born into a wealthy
family in San Francisco,
Sidney had not had
experience with such hardships.
But a book that Sidney reviewed
in the Pacific Weekly seems
to have had an effect on her.
Writing under the pseudonym Robin
Howe, Sidney reviewed "Waiting
for Nothing," by Tom Kromer, a
realistic autobiographical novel
about the hard life of a
vagrant traveling West.
She wrote, quote, "The Impact
of this book is like nothing
that has been written
out of individual experience
of the Depression.
It is stark as a winter tree, no
pathos, no plea, no art intervene
between you and the facts
of Kromer's experience,
facts which makes savage propaganda
because you feel they
cannot be born.
No conscious drama could improve on
the profound violence of this book."
This review was published the same
day that Sidney wrote her letter
to Helen Hall, which may
indicate that it had a role
in her decision to head East.
As she later said in
an interview, quote,
"I began hearing about
the Depression.
The Depression crept over the
country slowly, and in California,
you didn't hear about it too much.
But I began hearing things
and I decided I was having
much too privileged a life."
A little over a week after
Sidney sent her letter,
Helen Hall wrote back to say that
she would certainly be of use
at Henry Street, and Sidney began
to plan her first cross-country
road trip.
First, she had to convince
her mother
that driving was the best plan,
even though she was in her 30s,
summarizing her case
over several letters.
Quote, "I hate to pay out
cash for a railroad ticket.
One has nothing to show for it.
I've never driven across
the continent.
June isn't a bad month.
When do you suppose people
drive if not in summer,
and my tires are all
good for the moment.
And later, quote, "A
transcontinental trip sounds wild,
but after all, it's
only the trip from here
to San Francisco multiplied 20
times in various ways," unquote.
[Laughter] And finally, "No;
I've always wanted to drive
and I really feel equal to it.
It will be a grand luck."
On June 15th, Sidney set off
with a friend of a friend
who was relocating to New York.
Postcards that she sent
regularly to her mother showed
that they headed south from Carmel,
and spent over a week on a slow tour
of the Southwest before
needing to pick up the pace,
driving the long stretch
from Colorado
to New York City in just five days.
From Harrisburg, Pennsylvania,
she wrote, quote, "We're 189 miles
from NYC, a mere nothing to us.
Such perfectly beautiful country."
Sidney landed at the
Henry Street settlement
on Manhattan's Lower
Eastside on July 4th, 1935,
and began working at
Social Music Program.
Settlement houses were set up in
urban areas to offer social services
and activities that were intended
to have an assimilating effect
on the immigrant communities
with which they worked.
Music had been used
in settlement houses
since their inception
along two separate tracks.
Music schools taught
conservatory-style lessons
in Western art music as a mode
of uplift through high culture,
and social music programs offered
participatory music to people
of all skills and backgrounds,
with the expressed purpose,
according to scholar
Shannon Green, to quote,
"Ease relationships among members
of the community through music."
In particular, these social
music programs use folk music
that immigrants had brought with
them from their home countries,
in order to strengthen a sense of
community and ease communication
between different ethnic groups
living in the same neighborhood.
As part of her work at Henry Street,
Sidney collected Yiddish songs
from the older members of the Jewish
community to teach back to everyone
in group-singing programs
that she led.
In the end, Sidney spent just
eight months at Henry Street,
leaving in March of 1936 after
she fell ill with bronchitis.
But as we shall see, her time
in the settlement house proved
to be good preparation
for her government work.
In the summer of 1936,
Sidney joined the music unit
of the special skills division in
the Resettlement Administration.
This agency was tasked
with resettling those whose
livelihoods have been destroyed
by the Depression onto newly-created
homesteads, with a stated goal to,
quote, "Put houses, and land,
and people together in such a way
that the props under our economic
and social structure will be
permanently strengthened," unquote.
Homestead residences were a mix
of farmers whose land had failed,
jobless urban workers
willing to return to farming,
and unemployed miners and
other rural workers whose jobs
had disappeared.
The guiding principle behind
these resettlement communities was
to foster a cooperative
spirit that would do more
than simply boost morale
during tough times,
but would in fact inspire a
move toward cooperative farming
and a new sense of
collective purpose.
According to a 1935 memo written by
a staffer named Katherine Kellogg,
the goal of the agency's
special skills division was
to provide recreational
opportunities to, quote,
"Bind the homesteaders into
harmonious social units, to maintain
and build up morale, and to
relieve the strain of insecurity
until economic stabilization
had been accomplished."
These goals seem to echo
the settlement houses' use
of social music to
unify a community.
And in fact, Katherine Kellogg
had herself previously worked
at the Henry Street Settlement,
and her recommendations
for special skills seem to
reflect this familiarity
with the settlement
movement's ideas.
The music unit sent musicians to
several resettlement homesteads
to provide opportunities
for social music-making
and they also followed the
settlement house practice
of collecting folk songs
to teach in the community.
But here, instead of Yiddish
songs from the old country,
the Special Skills Division
focused on collecting folk songs
from the rural areas where most
resettled homesteaders came from,
with the expressed idea to
put this music to work, quote,
"As an integrating social force,"
unquote, on the new homesteads.
After persuading the government
to purchase recording equipment,
which was no small feat, the music
unit began sending specialists
on the recording trips
to collect songs
that would then be brought
back to resettlement homesteads
to be used in community singing.
The music unit was led by Charles
Seeger, a musicologist and composer
who had previously worked within
the radical Composers Collective
in New York City.
After Sidney had worked in the
Washington office as his assistant
for two months, she was sent on
her first road trip in July 1936.
According to her report, she was
sent to Western North Carolina to,
quote, "Get training and experience
in running the recording machine,
and in the rough and tumble of
folk song collecting under the wing
of a veteran in the
field," John A. Lomax.
Sidney's travel companions
on this trip were two
of the imminent folk music
collectors of the day.
John Lomax, who had recently been
appointed the honorary curator
of the archive of American folk song
here at the Library of Congress,
represented the public sphere,
and was considered a pioneer
in the recording of
American vernacular music.
On this trip, Lomax was
joined by Frank C. Brown,
a professor at Duke whose
focus on discovering survivals
of Old English ballads in the
songs of the rural Appalachians,
represented the dominant
interest for academic folklorists.
The first part of the trip was spent
visiting Dr. Brown's ballad singers
in the rural mountains near
Blowing Rock, North Carolina,
followed by a visit to a prison
in Boone, North Carolina,
where Lomax recorded songs sung
by African-American prisoners.
Sidney then went on
alone to meet the rest
of the special skills division staff
at the Folk Music Festival
in Asheville.
While Sidney was on this
trip, Seeger noted in a memo
to a supervisor that her experience
with these two collectors, quote,
"Reveals a flair for
diplomacy," unquote.
[Laughter] Sidney's description of
the trip in her own report shows
that she was adapted in
navigating the large personalities
and egos of her companions.
Quote, "I survived two days of
14 hours each and one of 17,
the driving of Misters Brown and
Lomax, their outrageous manners
to each other, and
the constant necessity
for impeccable behavior toward
the mountain people, our hosts.
Once Mr. Lomax recovered
from the notion
that a woman is a fragile thing
to be waited on hand and foot,
I was able to relieve him
with the driving and recording
and lugging odds and ends about
recharging batteries, et cetera.
I took note from Dr. Brown
-- " exclamation point,
"regularly from the beginning."
Reading about this trip, one
can imagine that these men,
both born in the previous century,
didn't quite know what to do
with a woman like Sidney.
Lomax found it difficult
to allow her to help,
and Brown could only view her
as filling the traditional
role of secretary.
But Sidney wrote that Lomax
did, quote, "Make every effort
to divorce himself
from the machinery
so I could have a shot at it."
And she noted with pride that
he, quote, "Ultimately offered
to leave his machine in my hands,
so he gather he felt sure
I could use it properly."
In addition to honing her
diplomatic and technical skills,
the trip seemed to help
Sidney carve out her own path
and developing methodology
for fieldwork.
In a memo entitled, "Observations
on Technique of Collecting,"
written just after the
trip, she wrote, quote,
"I came to the conclusion
that the collectors' visit
to make records should be a social
occasion, never a business one."
She disliked the way Professor
Brown seemed to push his singers
to recall songs, noting that,
quote, "A collector is after all
in the position of one asking
a favor, and he should be alert
to the fatigue of singer and player
and return another day
if necessary," unquote.
Sidney later said that she was
troubled by Lomax's treatment
of the African-American
singers from whom he collected,
calling it "domineering
and patronizing,"
though this actually
went unmentioned
in her original report from 1936.
Her response to all of
this seems to have been
to frame her own relationships
with her informants
on friendlier more
egalitarian terms,
though her written descriptions
could sometimes hint toward a kind
of detached ridicule.
For example, she wrote of one of
Professor Brown's singers quote,
"A man in his 40s who had but one
snag tooth left in his head sang
for us in a wobbly falsetto,
which Dr. Brown said was the
old mountain way of singing.
It sounded to me as if he were
simply unaccustomed to singing
and unable to control his voice."
[Laughter] Over time, she
became less prone to caricature
and judgment in describing
musicians,
but she often couldn't resist
including an amusing anecdote
about something they said, often
written in country dialect.
These stories, with a hint
of ridicule while often told
with the spirit of affection, are
also manifestations of the cultural
and economic divides that existed
between collector and musician.
This trip also helped clarify
her understanding of the kind
of music the special skills
division was interested in.
Their goal was very different than
that of academics who are focused
on capturing and classifying
remnants of a static history,
rather than on the rule of
music and contemporary life.
As she wrote, quote, "Dr.
Brown's classifications
of folks songs doesn't give
us the faintest idea --
the faintest hint along the
lines that are important to us.
What are people singing now?
What are people singing most?
Where is the live current as
contrasted with the antiquarian one.
His whole contact with contemporary
life is that of a man with his head
over his shoulder toward
the imagined perfections
of the past," unquote.
Sidney expressed strong feelings
about the importance of their work
in framing folk music as a living
tradition that held value in
and of itself, as she concluded
in a poetic tone not usually
associated with government reports.
Quote, "And here we are,
struggling to make our way
into the main current
of contemporary culture,
which we conceive as dynamic
and alive, drawing its force
from a thousand tributaries
which flow forward
with a perpetual meeting of
the waters in the future."
The resettlement administration's
interest in the social use
of music set them apart not
only from academic folklores,
but also from other public folk
music collectors, like John Lomax,
whose goals were focused on
preservation and dissemination.
Charles Seeger wrote that the music
unit's main concern should be,
quote, "To regard music
as a social function,
to direct it towards certain
definite social goals as an activity
of masses of people, rather than
merely of isolated individuals."
In other words, the music
unit emphasized group singing
and other group musical activities
to reinforce the resettlement
administration's goals
of fostering cooperation, and
they felt that the folk songs
that already resonated with the
homesteaders' rural American
identity served as the best
vehicle for this message.
I should note that in many ways,
the music program followed the
racialized thinking of the time,
and the systemic racism of the
Resettlement Administration,
whose homesteads were
strictly segregated
with only one community set
aside for African-Americans.
Thus, the music unit sought
music from white, rural musicians
for the most part, with
the unfortunate effect
that their definition of
American music focused
around these traditions, and this
even as the music they recorded,
complicated this binary with lots
of crossovers that I can detect
between black and white
musical traditions,
but that's a discussion
for another time.
In a series of song sheets
that Charles Seeger produced
to be distributed in the homesteads
-- sorry if you can't see those,
several songs with specifically
cooperative messages were included,
including "Cooperation is our
Aim," which is the top one,
and includes the coop
symbol of the two trees.
And "We Ain't Down Yet," which is
the second one, and you can see
in the art it has the sign
pointing to cooperate.
And this art was done
by Charles Pollock,
who is Jackson Pollock's brother.
And the other -- and I mean,
there are so many things
to say about this.
They issued, I believe,
eight song sheets,
and none of them had the
resettlement logo, none of them said
where they were from; also
discussion for another time.
So they also used well-known
folk songs with rural themes.
And in the case of a song like
"Wayfaring Stranger" -- so okay.
They also use well-known -- music
unit staff wrote new words meant
to resonate with the lives of
homesteaders in rural areas.
So here it says, "The following
modern verses from Virginia
and Florida respectively
have been received."
So the two verses on the top from
Virginia were from Charles Seeger
in Washington, DC, which I guess
they decided was close enough
to Virginia.
And the third and fourth verse
were from a music specialist
who was working in Florida,
but was from New York City;
so really fascinating.
So what I'm hoping to do is to
play a recording that the unit made
of Sidney singing these
last two verses
with Charles Seeger on the guitar.
But I don't know if
it's going to work.
[ Music and Singing ]
Given her wealthy background
and urban life,
these lyrics could
not have resonated
with Sidney's own experience,
but she may have identified
with the romantic idea of a
lonesome traveler after venturing
out on her own to collect
folk songs.
Sidney was sent on her first solo
recording trip in November of 1936.
Originally, the collecting was to be
made on the way to a new assignment
as a music representative in
the migrant camps in California,
driving cross-country along
what Charles Seeger called,
"The Broadway of America,"
leading through Tennessee,
Arkansas, et cetera.
Along the way, she planned to visit
several resettlement homesteads
in Pennsylvania, West Virginia, and
Tennessee, and she made connections
with a network of local folk
music collectors who pledged
to help her find musicians
in their area to record.
Sidney's resettlement administration
collection is not widely known
outside of folk music circles,
but when it is discussed,
it is usually in connection
with her work in the Ozarks.
She was among the first to
collect folk songs from that region
from musicians like the Duneune
[phonetic] Family shown here.
And she also held two
separate recording sessions
with Emma Dusenbury, an elderly
blind woman from rural Arkansas,
who is legendary among folk music
collectors for the astounding number
and range of songs
in her repertoire;
and John Lomax had
collected from her earlier.
Here I'll just play an example
of their session together,
which shows a bit of the warmth
that Sidney tried to cultivate
in her recording sessions.
[ Singing ]
And that was a play party game,
which Sidney often was looking
for as a kind of representative
of music
that was being used
in the community.
And I should just say, the other
aspect of her Ozarks collecting is
that there seems to be a love
story involved that I'm not going
to have time to talk
about, so you'll just have
to wait for the HBO miniseries.
[Laughter] So what I am going to
focus my discussion of this trip
on is her collection
of labor protest songs,
which went largely unmentioned
in her official field reports,
but are hidden in plain sight
in the recordings themselves.
In making plans for recording
sessions during her trip,
she confided in a letter to a
special skills staffer, quote,
"Of course, the thing
I'm most anxious to get
on the whole trip are
contemporary worker songs," unquote.
Just a few days before
she left Washington,
Sidney met with the
director of education
for the International Ladies Garment
Workers Union, who gave her a list
of union contacts across
the country.
In a confidential memo
about the meeting,
she noted that the union's
education staff traveled the country
with portable record players,
playing union songs
to get people to sing.
Seeing a clear connection between
the labor union's musical programs
and the goals of the special skills
music unit, she concluded, quote,
"Here is music as a social
tool being consciously used
with a very clear aim
and view," unquote.
Of course, all of this
interest in labor songs had
to be kept below the radar.
The resettlement administration was
already under fire from lawmakers
who felt it was too
costly and veered too close
to Communism in its goals.
Presumably, any music program within
the agency would have been seen
as frivolous, but one invested
in labor songs could
seem downright dangerous.
In fact, the entire music unit kept
an extremely low public profile.
The unit was not mentioned
in the special skills
division's annual report,
and many of their memos and
reports detailing their program were
marked confidential.
Syndey left Washington on November
7th, her car loaded with 250 pounds
of recording equipment
and blank aluminum disks,
and headed to the Westmoreland
homesteads near Greenburg,
Pennsylvania.
Her first recording session was
delayed by technical difficulties,
first by car trouble, then --
sorry, then because of malfunctions
with the recording machine.
In talking to a radio repairman,
she learned that many
electrical disturbances
in a small town would
interfere with the machine,
and because of this complication,
she had to cancel the next session
as well as she wrote in her report,
quote, "A little before 11:00,
a bakery nearby started
its electric dome mixers
and the intermittent disturbance
made recording impossible."
Finally, the next day, she was able
to conquer these technical barriers
to make her first solo recording
of a man with the wonderful name
of Tink Queer, a fiddler
accompanied by two guitarists,
perhaps exactly the kind of
music she had expected to find.
So here's an excerpt from
the end of one of the songs,
and then you'll hear
Sidney's voice at the end.
[ Music ]
[ Inaudible Talking ]
From here she traveled
across the Appalachians
and recorded ballad singers,
fiddlers, and banjo players
in West Virginia and North Carolina.
And I'm skipping so
much amazing material,
both in terms of the recordings
themselves and also the field notes
in her report are -- but I just
couldn't fit everything in.
Then she arrived at Cumberland
Homesteads near Crossville,
Tennessee, where she recorded
her first labor protests songs.
With help from Cumberland's
music specialist, Leonard Kirk,
Sidney had set up a recording
session with the Garrett Family,
homesteaders and musicians with
a deep repertoire of songs.
This is her official report
from her visit with the Garrets,
and it's uncharacteristically
short, a straightforward list
of the songs she recorded without
any of the colorful descriptions
or asides of her previous
reports which often went
on for several single-spaced pages.
And there's also no mention
of contemporary labor
songs being recorded here.
These missing details appear in a
confidential report that she sent
in later, which begins, quote, "I
won't again try to combine recording
of labor and more orthodox
songs in the same locality.
It is too difficult to manage."
And she later described how
they kept things quiet, quote,
"I told Kirk to be careful to
cover the Garrets and Phillips
by being a little vague
about just what I did record,
and by mentioning some of
the old songs they know."
So here's an excerpt
of Sidney's recording.
This is Henry Garrett singing
"Strike it Harem" [phonetic]
in Tennessee, which is an adaptation
of a traditional song called,
"The Hills of Roane County," with
new words by Herschel Phillips,
recounting a recent
strike at a local mill.
>> "Strike at Harriman, Tennessee."
It is written by -- it was
written by Herschel Phillips.
[ Guitar and Singing ]
>> Sheryl Kaskowitz: After
Tennessee, Sidney stopped
for brief recording sessions in
Little Rock and the small town
of Clinton, Arkansas, before
continuing on to St. Louis.
There, she met up with Joe Jones, a
painter and Communist part activist
who had visited the special skills
DC office earlier that year.
He had described the songs that had
been sung during a citywide strike
that September after the City
of St. Louis cut many citizens
from its relief roles, and Sidney
wrote that she felt determined
to record them on her trip.
Just as in Tennessee, there's no
official report describing her
activities in St. Louis.
And this time, even a
confidential memo was too public,
perhaps because of the involvement
of known Communist party activists.
Instead, Sidney wrote
a personal letter
to special skills director Adrian
Dornbush, and mailed it to the home
of another special skills
staff member, just to be safe.
She recorded four full disks,
about 15 different songs sung
by a multiracial group of activists
who arrived throughout the day,
quote, "Sent in by the grapevine
operating among the comrades."
The session had, as she described
it, almost a party atmosphere
with everyone drinking beer
and chatting between takes.
This session seemed to
convince Sidney of the power
of these kinds of protest songs.
So she wrote, quote, "I used to
be rather scornful of the tendency
of radical groups to adapt
a familiar song instead
of writing their own.
But one couldn't hear them
sung as I did on Tuesday
without believing thoroughly
in their living quality.
They are certainly not
being fed from the top."
She took note of one song
popular among garment workers sung
to the tune of "Rock-a-Bye Baby,"
noting quote, "The girls adore
and are perfectly aware of the
light irony in the contrast
between the bitter words
and the childlike tune.
>> "Rock-a-Bye Baby."
[ Singing ]
>> Sheryl Kaskowitz: The song
that she found most impressive
on this trip, writing that it
was, "Alone, worth the trip,"
was the blues implected chant
aimed at St. Louis Mayor Dickman.
She wrote, quote, "This is the
one thing that was sung so much
at the demonstration at the
City Hall, the sound rolling
out into neighborhood
streets hour after hour.
She noted that it was
set to an old blues tune,
saying that the dirge-like tune
was sung, quote, "With a dark,
patient quality of tone,
monotonous and threatening
so that my scalp tingled."
>> The Dickemann Song.
[ Singing ]
>> Sheryl Kaskowitz: From St.
Louis, Sidney went to Springfield,
Missouri, where she was
told that her assignment
in California did not go through,
and was called back to Washington.
After two happy weeks spent
recording in the Ozarks,
she returned to DC in January
1937, having traveled more
than 4600 miles, and collected
85 disks of materials to deposit
in the Library of Congress.
But this first solo trip would
be her last official trip
for the Resettlement Administration.
By the time Sidney was
back in Washington,
the Resettlement Administration
had been absorbed by the Department
of Agriculture, and the Special
Skills Division lost its support.
As funding for the
music unit dwindled,
Sidney received a new
assignment as a community manager
at a homestead in Austin, Minnesota.
Though there was no musical
component to her job there,
she held onto the special
skills recording machine,
and collected folk music on the
side, this time including the music
of ethnic immigrants,
the first collector
to do so, and call it American.
In the fall of 1937, she
left Minnesota and returned
to California, where she would go
on to direct the California
Folk Music WPA Project.
"So if the Resettlement
Administration's music program
lasted just two years, and Sidney
Robertson was involved for even less
than that, why does the story need
to be told," one might ask oneself
after spending four
months in an archive.
[Laughter] For one thing, Sidney's
contributions to public folk music
and to the academic
field of ethnomusicology
in the US are often overlooked.
If Charles Seeger is seen as a major
figure in both of these arenas,
then Sidney's role should also be
recognized, since she was the one
who tried out his collecting
methodologies in the field,
and participated in his efforts
to value the social role of music
within a culture, an idea that
was transformative in many ways.
There's also certainly an important
legacy in the recordings themselves.
Sidney's recordings are not as well
known as those recorded by Alan
and John Lomax, largely because
she did not share the Lomax's drive
to make her discoveries
available to a wider audience.
Perhaps Sidney needs to be
recognized as at least a kind
of godmother of the folk revival.
She certainly seems to have had
an influence on Mike Seeger,
Charles' son and Pete's
stepbrother, who recorded many
of the songs she collected
and later wrote to her, quote,
"I'm very thankful of your
field collecting in the '30s,
and remember your visits, which were
always a special family occasion."
And why focus on these more
obscure labor songs rather
than finding lost musical
gems in her recordings?
Well, I am fascinated by the
special skills division's covert use
of music on the resettlement
homesteads.
I think it's a really
interesting moment to explore
when a US government agency showed
a belief in the power of music,
and acted on it in a way
that I think would be
surprising to many Americans.
And I think this official
embrace of folk songs
as representing national identity
while problematic and complicated
in many ways, did have a lasting
impact on our musical lives.
In an oral history
interview, Adrian Dornbush,
the director of Special Skills,
said that the divisions
folk music activity, quote,
"Is the one tangible thing that
we did in the special skills,
which has really lasted and boomed."
Many studies of the Resettlement
Administration focused
on its failures, which
provide lessons and warnings
about overreaching
government programs.
Recently, though, scholars
have begun to look more kindly
on the administration's legacy.
Historian Robert Langinger
[phonetic] points
out that many homestead communities
still exist and even thrive,
like Cumberland homesteads
in Tennessee,
which has now become
an upscale suburb.
Within the visual arts,
the photography unit
of the Resettlement Administration,
renamed the Farm Security
Administration in 1937 is recognized
as having a profound and lasting
legacy, both in the photographs
that were created, and
in the later careers
of the many talented
photographers that support it.
Through my study of Sidney's
collecting during the Resettlement
Administration, I hope to
illuminate a musical legacy as well.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
Yes?
[ Inaudible Comment ]
Sheryl Kaskowitz: Sure.
[Laughs]
>> So thank you making
this presentation.
I had two questions.
>> Sheryl Kaskowitz: Okay.
>> [Inaudible] I was really
fascinated by the contrast
in approaches that you
mentioned, the [inaudible]
versus those who were [inaudible].
>> Sheryl Kaskowitz: Yes.
>> And I wonder if you had any
information on how she sort
of maybe sort of -- what
were discussion criteria?
Like she made an effort to seize
like performances of these songs,
or like to visit later sites
where people might be using them
like [inaudible]; and
then second sort
of related question is
[inaudible] having an effect
on shaping the [inaudible] of --
or what effect that they've
had on shaping [inaudible].
>> Sheryl Kaskowitz: Yes.
I mean, that's a great question.
I think, you know, she was still
carving it out in many ways.
What she talked about is --
so part of what she did
is that she would meet
with like a local folk music
collector who knew the region,
and that person would
take them to the singers
that that person knew about.
And so she was often sort of
dependent on those filters.
Sometimes she would
just go and set up --
like she'd set up in a grocery
store, you know, in a rainstorm
and collected some songs.
But what she said is
that often it would be --
they would be talking to -- she
said this about Frank Brown,
that he was really focused on what
the older people were singing,
and she would try to talk to
the kids, and things like that.
But that being said, she often
got kind of sucked into the --
especially when she was in
North Carolina and other parts
of the Appalachians,
the sort of excitement
of finding these old ballads.
And so even though she did
try to set herself apart,
she was still collecting
those things.
But in terms of like what the
Resettlement Administration was
interested in, and wanted to use,
yes, I mean, I think that a lot
of it -- it was not a
strategically planned thing.
And that, I think, is part
of what she was good at,
was sort of finding her
way, showing up in a town,
asking if people knew singers,
and kind of seeing what she found.
And then for your second
question about the canon, I mean,
I've been thinking about that
a lot, and one of the things
that I started doing was
tracing songs that --
like Mike Seeger songs that
traced themselves back.
Another place to look
is Ruth Crawford Seeger,
who is Charles Seeger's second
wife put together folk songs
for children.
And she thankfully noted
who collected what.
And so she was another person
who you can see kind of remnants
of her songs in there, and songs
that I'm familiar with
because of that.
But it's hard to trace
those lineages.
I think, you know, this idea
because she wasn't as interested
in putting things forward, I mean,
in the hands of another collector,
we might all know about
Emma Dusenbury, for example.
She might have, you know, tried
to, I don't know, I mean, you know,
bring her to urban audiences
the way that the Lomax's did.
So that's something that
I'm still exploring.
I mean, I do think that it's there.
And, I mean, I guess the
other thing is that she --
Allan Lomax kind of came on
the scene just after her,
and so she ended up mentoring him
in certain ways, giving him contacts
for his -- when he went to the
upper Midwest, he got contacts
from her, and things like that.
So I'm kind of trying to
tease out her influence --
and it's very easy to, you
know, over-blow it, obviously,
but I do think it's there, so.
>> It's a very small question.
>> Sheryl Kaskowitz: Yes.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
Sheryl Kaskowitz: Yes.
Blues music?
>> Yes.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
Yes.
>> So I was wondering about
that [inaudible] in relation
to the music of the 1930s.
>> Sheryl Kaskowitz: Of the 1990s?
>> Thirties, [inaudible].
>> Sheryl Kaskowitz:
Oh, of the 1930s.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
Yes, yes.
Yes.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
No political orientation, oh.
[Laughs]
[ Inaudible Comment ]
Yes. Well, I mean, this is something
Cathy and I talked about a lot.
She said in an interview,
"Oh, I, you know,
wasn't a member of
the Communist Party.
A lot of my friends were.
I thought it was sort of
silly the way they thought --
" you know, she thought
it was kind of nave.
But we've talked about the fact that
Sidney seems to have kind of set --
she doesn't come across
as extremely political.
And she kind of sets herself
apart like as an observer almost.
So what I can't tell with the labor
songs is how much it was the method
that the labor activists were
using in terms of using this music
in this particular way
to change people's minds
and make them feel united,
versus the actual message of --
[ Inaudible Comment ]
Yes, exactly; exactly.
Yes; and in terms of
your blues point, I mean,
that's something that,
you know, kind of --
what I was getting
at about this idea
that the music complicates the
binary that people try to set
up about, "We're looking at
white music," because it's --
when you're listening to
the music, you can't pull
out all of those threads.
And yes and so I think --
yes but certainly the issue
of race is one -- it's --
that I'm going to need to
explore more fully, so.
Yes.
>> Yes, hi, [inaudible]
presentation.
I was wondering [inaudible].
>> Sheryl Kaskowitz: Oh,
archives of labor songs.
Anyone in Folklife know?
[ Inaudible Comment ]
Yes; I mean, is it the
University of Wisconsin that has --
I know that there are collections
of like labor papers and --
but I don't know -- it's
a really good question.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
Yes, and I don't know if
they're even tagged to be able
to find them in the collection here.
It doesn't seem like
the kind of thing
that at least the government
collectors were doing.
I actually don't know
if that's true,
if the WPA collectors
were doing that as well.
>> Can I make one more
comment about your remarks
about the possible
connections [inaudible].
>> Sheryl Kaskowitz: Yes.
Of course.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
Yes; right.
And so yes it's hard to know
with her reminisces also how much
of things that are interfering --
or not interfering but contributing
over time that if you asked
her later, you know, I mean,
that question in an
interview, "Were you a member
of the Communist Party," you
know, it obviously is going
to evoke lots of feelings.
[Laughs] But it does seem that
she had this kind of apolitical --
even though she was writing for
this very political magazine,
for example, her music columns were
just completely separated from that.
It was just "Oh, this person came
and they played a lovely Schubert,
and then they did -- " you know?
And I don't -- so that's, again,
something that I'm kind of trying
to like wrap my mind around about.
Yes.
>> In working with the 1938 to 1940
[inaudible] Sidney recorded a lot
of music [inaudible] genocide.
And then and the songs
are about the genocides.
She never mentions
in her correspondence
or field notes the fact of the
genocide, or she records [inaudible]
in Fresno in 1939, which is is right
-- Franco is sort of [inaudible].
And she again somehow says,
"Well, they were very reserved,"
but doesn't say anything
about [overlapping].
>> Sheryl Kaskowitz: Why; right.
And I think that's part of
why I was having this question
about the labor songs, that
it really had to do more
with the technique than the,
you know -- what would that be,
the medium more than the message.
Because she didn't seem to
ardently like follow, you know,
or express strong feelings about
the ideas behind the labor movement.
She was just really interested in
the way that they were using music.
>> I had another question.
>> Sheryl Kaskowitz: Sure.
>> [Inaudible] from the age of 40,
she was incredibly
protective of the singers.
Now, this is after more Lomax
had done a lot of her [inaudible]
and she had already done
the recording [inaudible].
But she would say on the recordings
that no commercial use will ever
be made of these recordings.
And a lot of the recordings
[inaudible] catalogue
that was created by WPA
workers saying it was scripted,
but perfectly in her
[inaudible] and it was scripted.
And some of that I think contributed
to people not knowing
as much about her work.
I wonder in that earlier theory, did
you find that she was protective?
I think -- didn't Charles Seeger
go and play some records of hers
without asking her at the White
House and she was sort of incensed
that -- so I just wondered --
>> Sheryl Kaskowitz: Yes.
>> [Inaudible] from that earlier
period that she had that sense
that she'd better protect this
from these [overlapping] --
>> Sheryl Kaskowitz: Yes; she
definitely talks about that,
and that wasn't something
I included in this talk.
But she -- there is a lot of back
and forth about just how to deal
with the ethics of collecting.
And I think that she definitely
fell on the side of privacy, or,
you know, I think that the
government really did not want
to look like they were
exploiting people, right,
if they recorded these
songs, you know,
like the early recording
companies were going and doing,
and recording songs and
then making lots of money.
So I think that that definitely had
to do with why she's not well-known,
and why her singers
aren't more well-known.
Because -- I mean, you heard --
I don't know if the sound quality
was bad, but in that announcement
that she made on almost every
recording, she would say, you know,
it's not for commercial use.
And I think that was developed by
the Resettlement Administration
as a way to show, you know, we're
not making money on this and -- yes.
So but it is something
that it's really --
and it changed over
the course of her life.
She got into fights with Alan
Lomax much later and she wrote,
saying like, "Is there any way
that I can copyright the
songs that I recorded."
And so I think that she kind
of went through -- yes some --
I don't think she ever had like
a clear idea of her vision of it,
but she certainly was
more protective
and more private about
her collections.
So do we have time
for one last question?
Sure.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
Yes; I mean -- yes and
certainly it was --
I think that was part of what
the collectors were struggling
with was once you had something
recorded, what did that mean?
You captured it in one way,
but it couldn't really be
captured in other ways.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
Yes, exactly.
And, you know, I mean, that's
the folk tradition, so.
>> Nancy Groce: Folks, I think
we're going to have to wrap it up.
And I want to thank
everybody for their patience
with the technological difficulties,
most especially you, Sheryl.
>> Sheryl Kaskowitz:
[Laughs] Thank you.
Thanks very much for coming.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.